hi there steve kaufman here
um i haven't done a video in a while uh
today i'm going to stray a little bit
from the subject of language learning
and talk about education
and and it's still language learning
it's something that caught my attention
it was an article that i saw on the web
i think in linkedin where there's a
language learning
group or community within linkedin and
the subject was that stanford university
is going to
get involved in establishing something
called common core standards for english
and that this is going to help the
you know the increasing number of kids
in north america that's the us and in
canada who are in the school system and
who are not native speakers of english
and who very often struggle
with their uh school work
because of language difficulties and
they're often in esl classes and and so
forth and sometimes they fall behind in
their schoolwork
um and i've mentioned i've given uh some
excerpts and a link to this report at my
blog the linguist on language
but i thought i would add to my
blog report blog post as some comments
the gist of it is that they're going to
have meetings amongst educators and
commissioned papers on
topics about the need to leverage common
core standards for the for english
language proficiency proficiency
development
blah blah blah
and the feeling is that this is going to
be a tremendous benefit
to
these english language learners
i must say i am
totally i cannot understand what it is
they're trying to do i've seen so many
examples here in canada of these
programs over three or four years where
people get together educators teachers
administrators and they're trying to
develop new standards and so forth
we have language benchmarks in canada 12
levels they have the common european
framework in europe which is six levels
everybody is coming up with new
standards new frameworks new tests
um we're investing more and more in
education as i pointed out before in the
united states and it's similar elsewhere
since the late 60s the
cost of educating someone in the school
system has gone up
350 percent
and the results are
the same or possibly worse
when it comes to measurements of
literacy
of knowledge of history and so forth so
that the additional investment and this
is it
after inflation
three and a half times the cost has gone
up and the results are the same or worse
and it's because of this kind of
bureaucratic administrative
jumping through hoops
um
you know to me the issue is how much do
the kids read
every
study that i've seen shows
that the literacy level in other words
how well someone reads is the best
indicator of how well they'll do in
school
and
uh you know rather than having tests and
and of course we've moved away from
uh the kinds of tests where people
actually have to write anything it's a
lot of multiple choice and this kind of
thing the big issue is how do you get
kids to read
uh coming up with new standards for
english even the existing standards a
lot of the kids that are non-native
speakers of english can't even
whatever our standards are now they
can't seem to achieve those standards so
getting higher and more demanding
standards isn't going to do much unless
you get them to read i don't know of
anyone who reads a lot who doesn't also
read well
reading is one of these things the more
you do it the better you get at it the
more words you're exposed to
and so the issue is how do you get
people to read
are there poor people who don't have
access to books maybe
maybe
can we use you know the kindle and such
devices to allow kids to have more
access to books
uh should we allow them
to perhaps have more freedom in choosing
what they're going to read
you know this relates back to language
learning but i spoke to a teenager the
other day here in vancouver who said he
hated french at school because they
never had a chance to read all they did
was study grammar and do tests
that's what he told me and and he was
there with a friend of his who said yeah
that's what we do
i don't think that's the case in all
school systems
but
you know very often i mean i remember
when i was at school
uh we had uh one of many very
uninspiring teachers was droning on
about something
and one of our uh classmates stood up
and
took a put his hand up and said sir
uh can i go to the library and read
well
of course everyone in the class laughed
the teacher turned red in the face and
shouted at him and threw out of the
classroom
but
you know maybe he'd be far better off in
the library reading
things that are of interest to him
and so to me all of this new standards
new tests
what are they going to do here they're
going to meet and and webinars and
sponsor meetings and of course they'll
have donuts and coffee and stuff
it's much simpler
how do you get people to read
and i think that
that reading is very much related to
listening and we have these tremendous
devices now called mp3 players
which can enable you know beginning
readers to hear stories before they
start reading them which makes it easier
for them because they're not familiar
with it
uh
i think we have to say how do we
encourage
people to discover the joys of reading
because once you have that skill it's a
tremendously powerful skill it's like
being able to type quickly
it's one of these skills you have to
invest in in acquiring that skill and
then all kinds of things become possible
you then if you're a good reader
you can actually become an independent
learner at least in an academic sense uh
you know people can learn different
things people can learn you know nature
study and how to make uh machinery and
and and there's many things that you
learn through experience and not
necessarily through reading but reading
is pretty key nowadays
i saw a presentation which indicated
that the
english
level required to read manuals even for
basic
jobs was very very high uh you know math
books even science books are written in
very difficult english if you don't read
well you won't do well in math and
science the core competence is
reading
and so why don't we figure out how do
you get people to read in the classroom
and rather than allowing the teacher to
monopolize so much the time in the
classroom
or
uh trying to engage the students in all
kinds of uh you know make work type uh
you know team learning and uh
you know whatever they do in the
classroom group think type of stuff let
them read let them read in the classroom
if they don't have the habit of reading
at home at least try to cultivate that
habit in the classroom and in that
regard i fully support the ideas of
stephen krashen uh with his extensive
reading let people read and i think that
would simplify uh things and therefore
we wouldn't have to spend millions of
dollars on uh reestablishing common core
state standards for english and all
these other
efforts at creating yet more reports yet
more standards yet more standardized
tests yet more
you know publications reports proposals
that really
so far at least haven't produced any
results because as i said
at the beginning
with an increase of 350 percent in the
cost of k-12 education in the united
states uh the results are actually worse
than they were
uh
30 or so 30 40 years ago so there's my
take on that i i could be very wrong on
this somebody will explain to me what
exactly they are going to do but when i
see this thing about common core
standards for english i just see a lot
more bureaucratic uh
you know
ceremony
which will again produce very little in
the way of improvement in the english
standards of these non-native speakers
who are in the english language school
systems in north america thank you for
listening